extractive industries involved in oil
gas minerals and logging will have to
disclose full details of the payments
they make to governments thanks to a law
on transparency adopted by the european
parliament in the past corrupt officials
have pocketed millions depriving their
countries of revenue but after 18 months
of battling for it the parliament
negotiator says it's already having an
effect beyond europe's borders
we think the pressure now is on and we
understand that china is now thinking
about moving towards this we understand
that our campaign groups have taken such
courage and such strength from what
we've done is they're not campaigning in
australia they're campaigning in hong
kong to ask for the listing rules to
make sure that that you can only list on
a stock exchange if you comply with the
rules of of transparency for campaigners
in resource-rich developing countries
it's a breakthrough
a group of major figures from europe's
movie industry have been talking to meps
in a bid to ensure the creative arts are
not forgotten in the investment and
trade deal being negotiated with the
united states they want the parliament
to help fight their corner because they
say their concerns are being ignored by
the commissioner
foreign
meet the latest addition to the european
commission nevin mimicher has already
faced mep's who questioned his plans for
the mandate at a preenery session his
appointment was confirmed overwhelmingly
he'll be responsible for consumer policy
and will serve from the 1st of july
until the 31st of october next year when
a whole new commission is elected